♪ ♪ ♪
- Toronto, capitale économique
du Canada, une ville où
les inégalités sont criantes.
Vivre dans la Ville Reine
a toujours été dispendieux,
mais la crise inflationniste
marginalise de plus en plus
de Torontois.
Jae, 44 ans, vit les effets
de cette crise. Chaque semaine,
elle fait deux heures d'autobus
pour aller à la banque
alimentaire.
Sur place, elle trouve
des produits frais et
des denrées non périssables.
Pas assez pour une épicerie
complète, mais suffisamment
pour lui permettre de tenir
quelques jours.
"Chaque cent compte", explique
la Torontoise. C'est en 2018
qu'elle s'est rendue dans
une banque alimentaire
pour la première fois.
Jae avait ensuite réussià stabin
financière; de cliente,
elle était même devenue
bénévole pour Daily Bread.
Mais avec l'inflation, c'est
le retour à la caseépépart.
Le cas de Jae est loin
d'être isolé, alors que
de plus en plus de Torontois
ont besoin d'aide alimentaire.
Daily Bread est aux premières
loges de cette explosion
de la demande; c'est une
des plus grandes banques
alimentaires de Toronto avec
près de 200 points de service
aux quatre coins de la ville.
Chaque jour, des milliers
de kilogrammes de nourriture
transitent par l'entrepôt.
Le rythme est soutenu,
la machine, bien huilée,
de quoi donner le tournis.
"Nous avons dû trierer
la quantité de nourriture
très rapidement", explique
le PDG de Daily Bread.
Le nombre de clients mensuels
de la banque alimentaire
est passé de 65 000 en 2020
à 170 000 aujourd'hui.
Parmi ces nouveaux clients,
beaucoup de familles et
de personnes qui travaillent à
temps plein mais qui n'arrivent
pas à joindreeses deux bouts.
Face à cet afflux de clients,
Daily Bread doit mettre
les bouchées doubles.
La banque alimentaire
compte sur des dons privés
et sur l'aide de bénévoles,
comme Roisin Stewart, qui donne
un coup de main en cuisine
deux fois par semaine.
"C'est devenu plus important
à cause du coût de la vie",
explique la retraitée, qui
constate l'impact de l'inflation
sur son propre portefeuille.
Mais même avec l'aide de
bénévoles dévoués, difficile
de répondre à la demande,
surtout que Daily Bread est
aussi victime de l'inflation.
Leur budget pour acheter
de la nourriture est passé de
1,5 million de dollars en 2020
à 13 millions cette année.
"Quand va-t-on atteindre
notre point de rupture?",
s'inquiète Diane Dyson.
La chercheuse souligne
que les banques alimentaires
ne peuvent pas, à elles seules,
mettre fin à l'insécurité
alimentaire.
♪ ♪ ♪
Devant l'absence de solutions
structurelles, des milliers de
Torontois comme Jae continuent
d'être confrontés à des choix
difficiles.
Dans l'autobus sur le chemin
du retour, avec son panier
plein de nourriture,
Jae peut enfin souffler
grâce au petit répit offert
par la banque alimentaire.
Une bouée de sauvetage,
alors que le quotidien devient
de plus en plus difficile.
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,
Radio-Canada, Tortoto.